what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame before I start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification Bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
as you guys already know if you have
watched two or more of my lives and you
do not subscribe we have beef okay beef
people so a couple announcements before
we start the show the first being that
all super chats will be read tonight
over ten dollars sorry guys I don't I
don't ever want to miss them but
sometimes I just can't get to all of
them so over ten dollars we will be
reading we really appreciate these
donations because they are going towards
getting blessing and 8K camera isn't
that right blessing
um okay another couple of announcements
the first being that we have two clips
channels the first is Pearl daily and
the second is just Pearl Eclipse
um we have two different editors on them
so you get a little bit of a different
editing style so if you want to see
different clips daily go subscribe to
that on top of that we have four
different membership tiers the first
being the five dollar tier which gets
which gets you a part of the which gets
you to be a part of the live chat the
second is you get to see a behind the
scenes Vlog of the penthouse okay I'm
sorry guys we haven't recorded it yet
but we will right
we will it's gonna it's on our list um
we also that way you get to be a part of
our Discord and we just fixed the link I
know some people said they had issues
with the link we just fixed it so if you
want to be a part of our Discord um
we're putting a lot of time and effort
into that this month we really want to
build a community on Discord with you
know it'll all be in the chat daily so
if you want to get a hold of me like you
know join the Discord also tier three
you get to connect with me on social
media and tier four you get a one-on-one
call with me once a month um I can
either help you with YouTube Some people
ask me for like live questions questions
with girls whatever you're welcome to do
that too but
um I really recommend YouTube I really
love helping people with YouTube and I
you know I've helped so many people get
to like 10 20 30 40 50k Subs so yeah if
you want help sign up for that tier on
top of that go follow my Instagram guys
I'm so close to 50K on Instagram it is
just dot pearly things you have to type
out the whole thing I'm Shadow band on
Instagram right now so make sure you
type it all out it's the same as my
username on YouTube Just with a DOT
after just
on top of that they took away my first
Tick Tock account they took away my
second Tick Tock account they took away
my third Tick Tock account but we just
hit 140k on my fourth Tick Tock account
you can you can you can take my accounts
away but you can't get rid of me I'll be
on the app
um so that's just pearlythings.4 and
then my backup account all right we just
got to 30k on that because
um they might take away my fourth
account so that's just
pearlythings.5 so four and five
um those are the next ones on top of
that guys we are so close to 400 000
subscribers um I think we're at 390 um
we're close to it so make sure you hit
that subscribe button a subscribe is
free a like is free a like is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out this content so make sure you
like it
um on top of that we will be having a
Members Only Live
um next week and if you want to get in
the show DM Eddie his link is in the
description so today I have a lovely
panel um we have some familiar faces
some new faces so um today why don't we
go around to your name your age your
relationship status and a fun fact so
you can start hello I'm Shahara I'm 28.
thanks for inviting me again
um I'm in a long distance relationship
and
a fun fact about me
uh I don't know I'm really into
hedgehogs
how many do you have I don't have any
because I'm kind of conflicted like
should I is he better off without me
okay
okay hi I'm Tiana I'm currently single
um I don't know a fun fact about myself
I speak a lot of languages I speak four
languages four yeah what do you speak
um French German Creole and English is
not so good
I just wanted to show off a little more
of course I only know a couple sentences
way good
um my name is Yasmin I'm 22 years old I
am currently taken and fun fact
um I'll
whales are my favorite animals another
animal one but yeah I really I really do
whales we love whales on this show we
love that's crazy that's actually meant
to do that that I know she did it that
is my favorite animal to that's so crazy
that was the best fun fact we've ever
had on this show and and you know why
it's her favorite animal okay
um so today
our topic is modern women think they're
tense
so um what made me think of this topic
is I went to Carnival recently now that
was an interesting experience experience
I've never been to a festival so it was
a lot to take in you went in blind I did
not know what I was signing up for
um a lot of ass
a lot of yeah there's a lot of
everything a lot of everything anyways
so I went around and asked people to
rank themselves one to ten and the most
common answer I got from women was I'm a
10 I'm a 10 I'm a 10. and to me like a
10 is that you're perfect
which to me is a little bit narcissistic
so why why are people so quick to say
that they're a 10. oh
I mean you have to kind of
think that like people will always be
drawn to confidence you can't just go
around saying I mean
um I mean even if you are like
subjectively gay
I don't know five six maybe
um you can't you can't let everyone know
that you have to be like no listen I'm a
10. you don't think it's delusion
I think confidence is sexy so even if
you aren't like objectively or
conventionally attractive someone that
is very Charming is still seen as
attractive or just Charming in general
but it's not like true confidence or
it's not just arrogance
I don't think it's arrogant because I
don't think having confidence makes you
arrogant but it's like why are they
confident so if they know that they're
not they don't really feel that they're
attend but they're just saying that
they're a 10. it's a good point I guess
it's more than like attractiveness as in
how you look it's almost like I feel
confident myself you cannot be that you
might have like
pimples or like scars on your face but
if you're a confident person you can
still be a 10 no wouldn't you say that
means you have no room to improve
I think I understand what you mean but I
feel like
um I don't really like this idea of like
humans having to constantly improve
themselves because it means that we're
in a Perpetual state of not enough I
feel like it's kind of good that some
people have accepted like oh I'm just
good as I am because then you know it's
a happy state to be in yeah you could be
good as you are as a five
it's not an insult that's average you
know yeah there'll always be someone
that will uh like you yeah there's
someone for everyone definitely
there's more there's more women on the
planet than men
yeah so like by the Numbers there's not
some people get left behind you know
what I mean that's just like that stuff
out here
um so
um I have a clip for us to react to
where we kind of dived into this a
little bit blessing pull up the first
clip I I kept my original stance yeah
this one so this was you can see how far
the shows come because this was an old
show but it started from the beginning
blessing
yeah I started from the I don't know why
it started there yeah
foreign
like being a 10 is you're perfect
so do you do you think you're perfect
no I think there's Beauty in
imperfection you know Perfection is not
uh why are you talking over me I'm
Beauty and there's a difference anywhere
Jessica I believe that I'm an 11 out of
ten just because
I was not done talking
um I genuinely believe that Perfection
is not real but there's Beauty and
imperfection and I think no like you're
you're very attractive like I think
you're like I think you're attractive
but I don't know but wait wait wait can
you let me finish so what I'm saying
like like to me I would never say I'm a
10 because like a 10 is like perfect and
I don't think I'm perfect so I get like
is that but we were saying looks wise
right yeah and I genuinely see myself as
genuinely beautiful I genuinely see
myself as someone who is a goddess
because at the end of the day
Society is what decides on beauty
standards right right and I can I don't
have to follow that beauty standard
right I genuinely believe that I'm
beautiful yeah well and I'm not taking
that away from you I just like I just
could I just couldn't I just could never
say like I wouldn't say you're perfect
you know what I mean yeah yeah and
that's and that's what I'm not saying
I'm just playing around yeah I think I'm
really a 10 out of 10. like genuinely I
feel like I'm a 10 out of 10. yeah I
take care of myself what has given you
that uh my looks we were only talking
about look we were talking about
personality or skill or anything like
that is is that based on the way people
have treated you throughout your life no
this is based on how I was raised and
how I view myself and how I've worked
hard to see the beauty that I deserve to
see so I worked so you see an 11 out of
10 Beauty I wouldn't bro it's a joke
okay okay
yeah like I just said I consider myself
a 10 out of 10 for sure so you think
you're up there with so who would you
see in like the media that's like a 10
out of 10. why are we going based off of
media people no like why does that
matter well because because on society
well because that like society's Beauty
I don't give a [__] about Society that's
the key here is that I I have my own
Viewpoint right like okay so who would
you class as a 10 out of 10. what apart
from yourself well because like in order
in order to scale someone one to ten
someone has to not be a ten right so so
I fully agree with that yeah and so but
I'm not mine but we asked what I think I
am what she thinks he is what you think
you are I'm not going based off of
anybody else except for what I see in
the mirror right so but then like that
almost wouldn't be a scale that like
because then you have no way to measure
[__] right okay so it's like your
way of rebelling against the scale
almost forget Rebellion it's just
genuinely how I feel like and I'm not
saying like I like again like I think I
think you're beautiful like yeah
for you to say that you're a five out of
time right but I just think I live like
I'm not making no comparison in her own
right
yes but like you're in her own right but
I just think if I was if I was a 10 I
would have had modeling yeah
sorry we talk about programs
but do you know what I'm saying like I
think if I was like a 10 right then I
would have had model it I would have had
modeling contracts by now I would have
had people I would have had results to
show that I would have had NFL NBA
players but remember that is all based
on beauty standards that are set by
that's based on reality I do like that's
society that's reality and like but I
don't see the same way that other people
do though yeah let me ask the question
do you think there's an objective Beauty
standard yes
can you describe objective to me as in
like what the Baseline okay something
like an objective Society Beauty Center
so for example art is that good art or
is all art the same
I feel like that's kind of different
because art art is also something that's
all about perspective yeah it's
subjective yeah but in in in
if you look at Medieval buildings
especially Americans notice this when
they come here they love our Asian
architecture right compared to their
style there is a standard that's and
like a stick figure versus like Picasso
I guess um when it comes to that you
know art is something that you put time
and skill and detail into I can't really
say the same for people no because my
point is that as as genuinely human
beings can identify what's Beauty and
what's not
okay
so what is your reaction to this clip
what he was saying about
um you know we have ideas about what's
beautiful no I do I do think
I'm pretty sure like your brain is
kind of program to recognize certain
things as more aesthetically pleasing
enough even though subjective it's I'm
pretty sure there's even like certain
measurements of a specific type of face
that humans are more um
find more symmetry yeah like that yeah
there's been things like studies about
women with like neotenic faces like baby
faces that men tend to find more
attractive and babies like stairs stare
at for longer so I do feel like
there is an objective scale of
attractiveness that you can judge people
on obviously it's not like
cross-cultural like maybe a in the East
it's different but I feel like in the
west you can definitely say a person you
could write a person on a scale based on
what collectively in the west people
think and you could like write that on
one to ten do you believe that beauty is
in the eye of the holder the eye of the
beholder
I guess so because someone in East Asia
might not find someone in the west
attractive so it really depends on that
person like what they grew up with like
what they grew up was it um what they
their society grew up with that's
attractive would affect how they would
perceive a person so there's like
pictures of people that you might not
find attractive in like medieval times
but back then people would like kill
themselves or done crazy things just to
be with this person but like now we're
looking like oh I don't see the
attraction there so I definitely feel
like it's definitely a subjective
experience what do you think yeah no I
definitely feel that way as well and I
also think
um
your taste changes as you get older what
you might find attractive and what
you're drawn to initially initially when
you're younger or ultimately change as
you get older
um you might go for like the
the obvious pick but then as you get
older you might start thinking certain
different things or more beautiful do
you think that's for a manner for women
oh because because that sounds like a
woman's point of view not necessarily a
man's like I think I think when we get
older we're like well we don't
necessarily need these things but man I
I it seems like they just like hot likes
me yeah they're more uh visually
motivated than us yeah I feel like
they're more Primal than like women like
I don't know she hot in there yeah but
it's kind of cute because like some
women are like oh like I want my man to
have a nice job to be so intelligent but
I go like oh I think you're cute and
that's kind of enough listen what do you
think is Beauty in the eye of the
beholder
um I
yes in the term in in the um
when we're thinking about character so I
think personally for me I I rate myself
for four
physically really what yeah
but I generally like it doesn't bother
me I'm just I'm very objective about it
I I rate myself for four however I
honestly believe what we're missing
today is like everybody's saying that
what it appears to be everybody saying
that I'm a 10 I'm a 10 but they
misconstrued it in terms of their
personality everything as a package
there are ten so there is no room for
improvement and um I mean I'm thinking
about like at what point does humility
come in uh you know it seems like
non-existent therefore they won't really
do any you know introspection and are
they self-aware and all that stuff so
I'm just saying just saying you're a 10
it's just it's problematic but from what
I'm saying is that um so I think I'm a
four but with my personality and
everything and all my character all
these very important things they kind of
make the package they make the person
and these are the ways that people fall
in love
um you know with somebody's character so
I think that's what they're
fundamentally missing when they just say
there are 10. okay so you're a 10 but
what about your personality I'm a 10
there as well I'm just perfect all
around
which just comes across as arrogance to
me
what do you guys think of the body
positivity movement
in terms of what do you think it's good
for society
no
it isn't why
well uh who who's whose body are we
saying that it's that that they're fine
like what what change has have we seen
because no I'm just I just wanted to
know how you think uh well for example
like I think about a while ago I saw uh
a clearly obese woman uh on the cover of
a magazine I can't remember what
magazine it was but then they said very
clearly this is healthy and I'm just
like are they trying to manipulate me
into thinking that that's healthy and
she was in sportswear but clearly she's
not it's like clearly you ain't going to
the gym I know right and she's been on
the treadmill in a minute like come on
but but what I find generally
heartbreaking is that okay yes I'm I'm
physically Slim Right so people are
gonna be like oh you're just like fat
shaming but I genuinely have concerns
for her so when I see people who are
like oh yeah girl you're a 10 sorry I
can't speak like that I'm terrible but
yeah yeah you know yes Queen and I'm
like I'm it breaks my heart I'm just
like you don't care about her you're not
telling her you're not encouraging her
to change you know there's a risk of
diabetes are they saying um diabetes is
a 10 are they saying asthma is a 10 I
think depression is a 10. so yeah you
could say yeah you're a 10 but no one's
there when she's crying all alone and
she has all these health problems what
happens to all their energy then and it
is really heartbreaking a student and
and I've seen plenty of people who have
been obese and they've you know they've
made tick tocks and stuff and they say
um on The Tick Tock uh I've done this to
myself or I'm going to take
responsibility and then you see their
progression and there's so much happier
and they're not in that delusion and
somebody who genuinely cares about you
will tell you the ugly truth but they
are telling you they're not telling you
a beautiful lie and that's what you want
from a friend and that's what we should
have in society if we have everybody's
like oh yeah you're fine yeah you're
fine yeah you're fine
um it's actually really unfair and I'm
just thinking like in a way I think it's
really Sinister because if I was fat and
my friend told me you're fine I'm like
she doesn't give a [__] about me she
really doesn't she would have told me
this is you're actually ill you're not
well and the moment I get on that
treadmill and she's there by my side you
know championing me on I'm like well
that is a friend so the moment I see
people are like encouraging very
unhealthy Behavior Uh it really does
genuinely break my heart and I I just
like my journey ethics or whatever is
you know people say oh you're slim you
can afford to say that no I genuinely
care about people and I encourage them
and when I see people obviously are
yeah it really questions
um it makes me question their motives
like you have an agenda why are you you
know encouraging clearly unhealthy
behavior is that why you don't agree you
don't think the body to positivity
movement is positive no I I think well
it's false body positivity because it's
saying you're fine the way you are and
there is no you know improve there is no
uh they're not we're not championing
Improvement is what I'm saying okay I
think there's a good point that you made
um but I would like to like draw upon
like the opposite side of that like
obviously with bodied positivity it's
not just about
um like weight it's about like skin
texture skin color yeah but that's like
one of the biggest things I've seen you
you've said more between like weight
yeah I don't I don't really see skin
texture or skin colors marks that kind
of thing or like people that don't shave
we've got hairier yeah I mean well I
don't want to see that yeah why are they
putting that I miss the days when models
would make me feel bad about myself and
I would put their picture on the
treadmill and I'd start running yeah I
had to bring them back
I think you go find a balance because if
you go to the other end of the spectrum
and someone's really underweight and
it's being advertised it's it's not
gonna that's not so great I think you
are you will ultimate ultimately you are
fine the way you are because I don't
think no one can tell you anything if
you're having these health issues then
definitely needs to be addressed but um
yeah to be honest with you so you think
you're fine the way you are at 300
pounds
not necessarily you're not I do think
you should you should definitely do
something about that but I think it's
about being realistic if these types of
things are being shown on media then I
think it should be shown in a way to
show that listen
whether it's bad or good uh there are
people like this and they're still part
of society etc etc it doesn't it doesn't
on it doesn't deem you uh
a certain way in a negative way if that
makes sense don't you think it
normalizes it
because shouldn't obesity not be normal
shouldn't it be abnormal isn't that what
we should want I think obesity shouldn't
be the norm but I do feel like there are
people that are just going to be bigger
there's people are going to be smaller
regardless so like if people everyone on
the same diet people will still do
different sizes but it's not like
morbidly obese so I did say like not
obese I said like people are going to be
different sizes I think
um it'd be interesting if body
positively went in the in the way in the
direction that we're like okay they're
going to be people that are different
sizes and they're still a part of
society they still should be respected
we still need to treat them like humans
I think that's kind of what the
direction it should have gone in instead
of like normalizing um being more
believe obese I think that's what your
point but but I think people will say
when you say all shapes and sizes they
will put in morbidly base like that's
fine unless you explicitly say accept
morbidly obese but then you will be you
know shamed for fat shaming no like I
mean
like genetically like you're going to be
shorter I might be taller someone might
be I don't I don't want to say that use
the term big boned because it doesn't
really make sense but some people are
going to be broader and have one of
their shoulders like this is like the
reason why a lot of people pursue
different sports
um you just built different you know
regardless of diet and how how you train
you can't really change your genetics by
that much some people achieve certain
muscle formations that certain people
won't have yeah I want to show you guys
um something that I saw on Twitter today
I'm a blessing and this is I'm going to
send it to you you may send it on
Instagram
yeah because it's an extra one I don't
think it's like normal to the extent
here let me
uh okay
I saw a picture on Twitter today that
was like a beach from the 70 or like it
was before the 70s maybe 60s 50s and
obesity really wasn't normal then if you
go to a third world country it's not
normal even even like there weren't even
really overweight people
um and so I feel like
when you put them on the cover of
magazines it's like you're saying find
like find me attractive you must find me
attractive and when you're like uh not
really like I wouldn't want to look like
that ever at all not even a little bit
and they they say your body shaming but
it's just like honest do you know what I
have more issue with I don't really have
an issue with putting someone that's
large on in front of a magazine I have
more of an issue with like the
Magazine's intentions because a lot of
these big magazines have promoted like
hyper skinny or underweight women for
like the past 10 years the past decades
before and then just to put a larger one
in front of the magazine all of a sudden
is like yeah let's just forget all the
past women we promoted before and this
is the new standard of beauty I don't
really like that kind of narrative where
like okay we're just gonna switch up now
and this is what we support when that's
really not what they're about
what do you what do you mean because
like let's say you use like like Marilyn
Monroe she wasn't underweight and she
was like a pinnacle of beauty
yeah but she's like one woman yeah I
think that's the exception not the rule
when it comes to everybody had that
hourglass figure that's why it's so
iconic yeah I feel like that was like
because of the fashion at the time if
you look at the kind of the dresses that
they wear it's very like skirts are very
high-waisted and it's very tight at this
point I think it's more to the fashion
than emulating this type of style
also the body type followed if you look
more towards the 80s the more sporty you
wear when they're a bit more like fitter
and more athletic looking I think we
kind of the bodies followed the fashion
so like now you can see like low waisted
clothing coming into fashion women are
going to want to be a bit more Skinner
skinnier or thinner you see Kim
Kardashian taking her implants out to
follow that kind of fashion trend that's
going to come in
yeah like Y2K you might have heard of it
like a lot of that kind of fashion is
coming back so a lot of people are going
to try and be skinnier to match that
fashion I think like fashion and the way
people want to dress and look like kind
of follow each other
yeah yeah but and it's silly because why
change your body for a micro Trend just
be healthy you know but it's it's how
it's how it goes I just think hourglass
has always been like Maryland like even
if you look at Audrey Hepper and there's
another like I like I think it's not I
think it's a waste ratio yeah it can be
very thin and still have an hourglass
figure because you've got really wide
hips and a small like rib cage yeah
but you're not going to be like married
in Monroe Marilyn robes uh no I I agree
with you I think she wasn't very thin
but she had that shape yeah like I think
there's a difference between
like you know saying like we have
different body types but either way like
no no one's turning down Jennifer
Aniston and she's built more like Square
she was a pinnacle of Beauty in the
early 2000s she's not she doesn't have
that hourglass you know shape but you
know in the same era like Kim
Kardashian's also beautiful like I think
it's just like thin thinner oh this is
the picture from like the like look at
it there's not really obesity back then
everyone's ball in what is this in
America is there a picture of Are You
Gonna Do Is there is there more than one
I thought there was like three
oh that would have been good to have a
contrast but everybody kind of looks the
same
yeah that's what I'm saying like
everyone was thin for the most part so
it's almost like we're normalizing
something that shouldn't be normal
and saying find me a try like that's
another issue is that people that are
overweight feel like they can't be made
fun of just like everyone else oh
something crazy happened to me the other
day so I was in like a market in
Greenwich and I wanted to buy some jeans
and I was like there's like a way of
trying them on like using your neck to
see if it fits your waist it's like a
cool hack like you go around your neck
and if it fits yeah I've seen that if
it's you interesting and I end up buying
these jeans and like they fit in the
rooms like oh they look great on you I
was like oh perfect I'm gonna buy them
and walking away and the woman shouts I
hate skinny people
so imagine like I was just thinking yeah
yeah like in a joke way but like I just
thought to myself like no one really
makes the reverse of that joke I know
it's like cliche yeah you say I hate fat
people people be like yeah like no one
battered an eyelid yeah but I feel like
we've really normalized I don't know
like
these back like side comments towards
women that are a lot thinner and I feel
like we can't really talk about people
that um are obese the same way as we
used to the transparency is gone I feel
everything's sugar coated now anyways
yeah I feel like if When someone tells
you oh like you've lost weight like
it still has that same
I just feel like it's the same way as
saying oh like you're fat now I'd be
like oh I'd feel a bit like insecure
like no my parents don't really hold
back I'm not gonna lie me either I'm
like
I feel like it was good for me though
like I I think I would have been like
I've always been the type to like
struggle like I've had to work really
hard because I eat really bad like I'm
an athlete so it kind of evens out but
like
like honestly my mom when I was younger
would she would she fashioned me a
little bit she'd be like oh you got your
but honestly like it hurt at the time
but I'm so glad she did I got on the
treadmill
I think there's definitely something
that is important of like a parent being
like honest with that like Sono daughter
especially if they get into like a place
that's unhealthy
I think
um
it's a shame because a lot of children
are abuse like obese and childhood never
really lose
um will stay obese for the rest of their
life and then they have problems with
diabetes they die earlier and I feel
like if that was just addressed like
when they were young if they're honestly
like like your mother like maybe not fat
shaming but just you know I'm gonna help
you with your health that conversation
with her I think it would really improve
like just Health in general I feel like
fat chamber was the best way to do it
you look fat if it comes from a place of
love then why not if it's someone you
know you may not know then it's just
like sorry how dare you but if it's
someone like if your family it's
different yeah yeah of course like why
why not it's the truth it's not like
because being fat I mean it's not it
doesn't have to be
negative like unless you're obese and
you have actual health problems
ultimately
perhaps you need to change stomach in
your life if you feel like you're
gaining too much weight if someone's
telling you oh like listen I feel like
um you've put on a bit too much or it's
just like oh yeah no I know I know I've
realized as well it's nothing it's
nothing uh too personal you shouldn't
feel so attacked
okay blessing do the second clip
the I'm a 10 one
yeah that one
girls are objective or do you think they
think they're hotter than they are
or do they underwrite themselves go
around personally I think it depends on
the person because growing up I'm
obviously not skinny hi everyone I'm not
skinny so growing up I was never the
beauty standard for anyone so like all
my friends were getting chatted up by
people blah blah blah blah and I was
just the other one you know so like I
never really thought of myself as
an attractive person like I would never
call myself anything more than a fort
but now like I don't really care about
what anyone thinks about me like I've
grown into myself and I've I've I'm
comfortable with who I am now that like
even if I you guys call me delusional or
whatever I think I'm maybe not 10 let's
not go that far but like definitely an
eight per so like whether you guys think
I am or not yeah that's got nothing to
do with her but like what is it that
took you from a four to an eight if
nothing's changed what is it that takes
loving myself and and looking in the
mirror and not being disgusted at what I
see I understand that yeah so but that
doesn't you're you're not necessarily
being objective about how other people
view you right because isn't that what a
rating really is like what you think the
vast majority like like if I rated
myself one to ten I give myself a five I
think I'm normal looking and I just
think it's based on my results I think
if I was in eight nine or ten I would
have had modeling contracts because
people in the top 20 of beauty they get
they get modeling contracts what is
beauty so what what is beauty I mean
there's a lot of things like if you
I mean you can you can go online and
have people rate your pictures and they
rank you one to ten that's wild and and
so you can get you can get a lot of data
that says how attractive you are in
society and men will wait you women will
rate you like every day how we look is
like how we represent ourselves it's not
fun but it's just like being honest
so
um and it's also like you can get dating
apps like you know everyone's Tinder
Bumble like they have a ranking for you
behind the scenes
yeah down yeah well I trust so
um I don't understand when girls say
like I'm an eight because or sometimes I
hear girls say time because I hear this
a lot where they say like because I love
myself and I'm like confident now but
don't you think attractiveness is based
on results
they may be but I don't care about those
results
to be honest
but do you think then you're not being
objective about your how attractive you
are or how attractive anyone else might
be
um
I guess not but like yeah
that stuff's not really important to me
but I think when when someone when
someone rates somebody why why does that
have anything to do with them like if
you rate me if someone rated like
somebody a three and it's just like okay
that's that's your opinion like it's not
Okay so
my first question is based on this clip
do you think women are honest with each
other no no
no
what do you think Eddie Andrew said no
no way
do you think that someone that's
overweight can be above a five
yeah
oh that's a techie one there's men that
like fluffy women like there's
um
how many men
yeah but what do you mean by fluffy do
you know what I think we need to Define
what the like diabetes asthma wait wait
um can you can you Google
um
like BMI chart like do BMI chart
something like that
we can decide as a group because I think
you have to define the parameters
because I think have you guys seen Wally
Wally the movie like all the women and
the the people yeah dude everyone yeah
yeah you're the one with the the fat the
fat one yeah do that yeah there you go
can you make it bigger yeah yeah thank
you
well
yeah zoom in a little bit
the Red's kind of smaller than I
expected for like the red circle well I
think that's just like the max you know
like that's the minimum Max it keeps
going you know yeah so it can all right
we'll we'll do by color
and I'm not I'm not talking about body
shape obviously these aren't the most
voluptuous women you know but no cheeks
but just interesting sense
Okay so
um this is on the right on the left does
that say underweight I can't read it I
think yeah the blue is underweight
and then the green is that normal and
then overweight is the the
light yellow so yeah can someone be
attractive or like
above a five if they're overweight
yeah yeah I just think I think we need
to define the parameters because
attractiveness and wherever a woman I
said above a five above five it looks
wise like so it's like one to ten like
they're they're more attractive than
someone that's average if if the body
that I have in mind
goes to be treated 100 okay what about
obese obese it depends on the cheats so
you think that gut as long as there's
cheese that got it's a Madness but so
then with the answer be now well yeah we
have a god like that somebody what about
men there's a lot of men that also
decides that are deemed attractive or
are very successful with women what do
you think about like what do you mean
like ugly guys like it girls no like
overweight guys overweight guys they're
still seen as very attractive are they
Rich normally yeah literally yeah there
you go that's like the cheat code for
men I mean like men and women are
weighed on different things so like men
don't care about our money but our but
women care about men's money
I mean you could argue that maybe the
girls wouldn't have like genuine desire
for them they just want you know the
money but I don't know it depends in
Africa
um Big Belly's a sign of wealth yeah
that kind of wolf is attractive yeah
like different countries like they
force-speed the women to make them
bigger because it seems that's like one
small tribe in Africa and I will agree
and I looked at that tribe because I've
heard so much about this tribe
everyone brings up yeah that country is
in poverty so it's really not even the
majority of the country it's like a very
it's it's maybe because of that
because they're in poverty maybe like
food resources aren't very common yeah
and then to have those is kind of like a
sign of wealth yeah it's attractive I'm
assuming I don't know I just looked it
up one day and I was like this is the
smallest freaking tribe that I've heard
so much about validating like I'm so
tired of hearing about this tribe
and the other thing is like on the show
I've had so many people tell me like
they won't even tell okay you know I'm
gonna ask the panel this first is lizzo
a test oh no get a picture yeah let's
put can we put lizzo on the screen
let me think
looks including wait yeah it just looks
just looks oh man
I think that's too hard too I think I'll
go with five I'm gonna say neutral five
yeah five is average you know no like I
feel like she's got a really really
pretty face she's got a very symmetrical
phase and you cannot disagree with me I
will never take your opinion on board
I'm talking about her face I'm I might
actually even lost weight her features
will come out more like I think symmetry
is very attractive and she's a very
symmetrical face to me so I like her
face yeah because you know what when I
hear is she attractive in the face yeah
devoid of her body I think would I still
have sex with her but why is
attractiveness always gonna because I'm
a man but he's a man I was gonna say
he's a man I want to chop for both men
and women chop so no but men chop it but
he is like that's like you know yeah men
I feel like just go for what they see as
in like if if you're not if they're not
it says attraction yeah no the basic
principle is the men are attracted to
what they see whilst women attractive to
what they hear
so that's why men lie and women wear
makeup
I want to agree with you
yeah me but now I look at her face and
think I hate what you're saying
something she's pretty but that's just
me trying to be nice like I would not
give up okay one to ten Eddie one to ten
she's a she's a one
would be like something that's a little
bit more like 300 pounds no like 300
pounds no like like the face that you
could make a little space look worse is
what I'm saying yeah I mean I don't
think she's like like if if she was
thinner she'd be fine but she's 300
pounds but I don't think she's a one I
feel like the one
what about you what you think I don't
know I'd say um okay me just being
outside the whole motion I would say
four but then if someone was to come to
me if like someone I like if my
boyfriend wants to come up to him be
like listen I'm leaving you for her I'd
be like are you serious like you're
taking a pissed
your self-esteem is gone
so what did you give her a one and your
opinion probably matters the most you're
rating thank you why does it matter
because in terms of a sexual mate a
relationship everything
matter right it can be attracted to
women too yeah I know but I'm just
saying would you would you would you
because are you attracted to women too
okay so would you date lizzo she's not
my type
out in it
okay why do you think women have an over
inflated sense of ego
are they making excuses yeah I feel like
being a really objective is very
difficult so if you are like not
conventionally attractive you've had to
come to terms with that and accept that
maybe you're obviously not
conventionally attracted can we just say
ugly
today
why do I use words where like they just
meet like it's the same thing but Less
Direct
but you know what I mean yeah ugly so if
you're ugly okay so if you're ugly
um I guess that's very hard to come to
term with times with and I feel like if
I was if I thought I was ugly I'd be
like I'm gonna make a delusion I'm gonna
make a reality that that doesn't exist
because if you think you're ugly every
day I don't think you'd be very happy
but wouldn't it be better to like know
you're ugly and be like you know I'm a
fan of ugly man and be happy boom rather
than lizzo where she's like no but like
she doesn't realize she's ugly and so
now she's with a dude that's like
clearly with her for the money I mean
come on that's the problem in society
like women average women don't want to
date average men you think so average
women do not want to do it I I want to
agree with you but I can't because I see
so many women dating bums and so many
women that are dating like like you just
look at the woman and you're like wow
she's like a 10 out of 10. she's
beautiful she's got everything going
first but you lie so you're not honest
about how girls look so I didn't say I
didn't I gave a rating of a five yeah
that's yeah but the girls with the girls
that are with the bums like they're
usually average because if they're above
average they would they would get an
above average guy but you would think
that women are insecure no I don't I
don't think so I think women think
they're hotter than they are most of the
time and usually if it is a bomb he
knows how to talk and he's good looking
like girls don't date ugly bums if he's
a bum
and he's usually hotter than her have
you seen Angelina Jolie I don't know who
she was dating but I just didn't find
that I don't know who it was she's 40
with six kids no no no this was when she
was like young and I just looked at the
guy and I was like oh they're together I
don't remember who it was but like I
found that like did he have money
that's why she left him and got Brad
Pitt so yeah she did she got money and
looks like that's a woman do I don't
know when going for a guy you want to go
you're going to go for the one that's
the someone you can sense can kind of
Take the Lead even if even if he's not
so much uh
if someone that you can be submissive
with and he's going to be the dominant
one then if he can take on that role
what he said like women fall in love
with what they hear yeah so the position
that he plays Photoshop yeah and how he
makes her feel obviously us women wear
like the
yeah I'll be your pretty thing you I
have all the looks don't worry you just
do everything else that's it tell them
again but if you don't
or if you don't leave a woman no like
let's say hypothetical scenario if
you're talking about people that have
been ugly what did they do then they
date each other
serious but the the problem the problem
is is women only swipe right on dating
apps 5 to 20 on the high end percent of
the time where men swipe right 50 of the
time yeah so it's a very small
percentage of men that are having sex
with everybody and so the guys the guys
that are eights nines and tens are
sleeping with the force fives and five
and sixes and they the girl the average
girls think they're on that level but
they're not they think they're hotter
than they are and that's facts and so
then and so then when they get their
husband the guy that would actually take
them seriously they think they're
settling because but that's really just
the guy on their level but they've been
sleeping with they've been sleeping too
high
but I think that comes from the fact
that
a lot of women are born of value whilst
men have to create their value yeah so
with women you're always afforded to see
the sexual Marketplace which means that
you're going to get a 10 looking guy who
just wants to have quick sex and you're
going to seek to validate Yourself by
getting an attractive guy so you're
gonna get you're going to give that guy
quick sex but then you now think that
I'm on that same level as that guy
because you're afforded to see it almost
sexual Marketplace again what you mean
by like
I don't know like having that advantage
of
um having the privilege like when you
want to find like casual sex if women do
have that but I don't think women are
that naive to think that they can have
casual sex with a guy that that guy
would do would have a relationship with
me some women are like and nobody will
I'll give you an example so on the last
show I I said or it was a show or two
ago I asked the guys like have you ever
slept with a girl that you'd never be
seen in public with a bunch said yes and
then I was like and I was like okay how
long did you let that go on and some of
them said like five six months and so
those that girl like may think it's
going somewhere but it's going nowhere
yeah and like they're they're like
they're low-key embarrassed they were
talking about how they need to wash like
shower after yeah
is that kind of like like an ethical
like why do men want to do that that's
how that's how hardwired so unless a man
has discipline he naturally falls into
that Style with those characteristics
that's just how men have you slept with
someone that you regret 100 no to what
degree like I remember busting a nut and
thinking God why do I do this I went
Church oh it's not Curry I went to
church I bought something I went
straight to church again
what the hell I'm at here slaying
dragons like I'm awful what's going on
but that's the thing with men though
like you're luckily for women are your
standards on the floor like if you have
the free will to do that though that was
her choice and this is why I always be
me personally I speak about discipline
I've gone on Journeys like I took a year
at six to learn sexual discipline for
these reasons to get what I'm saying in
my Prime when I was mad young at
University I did it for the sole purpose
I believe it's important but I still say
that's a man's truth because again
that's your biological imperative right
now in society we cater to a woman's
biological imperative which is to be
more monogamous if we was to live by our
true means our strategy for survival is
scattergun that's what we that's how we
have so much
um
sperm
we literally because what men are Were
Expendable we die we go to war we take
risk so in order for our linear region
to survive we need to impregnate as many
people as possible so if you was to live
by a rural biological imperative we'd be
out here spreading our seed and
we get we get demonized for being
natural whereas women can we can cater
to your um biological imperative and you
know it's so funny I think women do get
also demonized if we're talking about
men no no like I'm not talking about
when you were talking about like
spreading your seed in that like
um women that have a lot of kids with a
lot of different men aren't really um
scene is very attractive in society but
that's like the natural way no no it's
not but but it is no no the natural way
is for women to reproduce with the
highest value guy possible and in
society we push that so skip that bag
yeah go for a future shot like that I
understand that but we're talking about
like you're talking about spreading your
seed and lots of different men how to do
that with lots of different women so
that means a lot of different women are
going to get pregnant a lot like quite
often and women with a lot of children
with different man is just not seen no
it's not it's not by so they get
pregnant by the highest value guy
possible so like throughout history it
would be like one man and a bunch of
concubines like how many how many people
are really related to Genghis Khan
so it's like polygeny so when the man
has multiple women
because he's able to if he's able to
look after those women then he has kids
from mobile women and they will raise
their children together yeah 8 000 years
ago it was 17 women for one man and only
historically 40 of men have reproduced
where 80 of women have and so like
historically even men reproducing was a
privilege
yeah but like when men reproduce it's a
privilege but like
it's also natural for women to get
pregnant that's not seen as a privilege
like women like it's natural to get
pregnant by one guy not but you can get
biologically like you can get pregnant
more than once yeah we get pregnant just
not at the same time well you're right
by it would be by the same guy it would
be like tribes so basically like like
I'm talking like
if men were just spraying the seat with
anyone like now uh-huh women could also
just get pregnant quite often with lots
it would be like in tribes so basically
like the men would impregnate the like
okay
the men and the women would have kids
right and then if a better like Warrior
took over the tribe they would kill they
would kill the kids take the women and
so like men are biologically repulsed by
other people's children like they're
just designed to not want to deal with
other people's kids and pass on their
resources to them you think so yes yeah
not only that but it was a study that
was I was gone would you would you date
a single mom no
are you gonna buy the single moms or the
kids
I guess McDonald's foods
to me I just gonna give you a kid I just
don't want all that baggage in it that's
to me that's unnecessary headache when
there's a bunch of other women who
haven't made that mistake aren't Men
supposed to be providers like
traditionally for next man's you yeah
yeah but like if you're at the head of
the tribe like Pearl said earlier and
you have multiple wives
the only delivers Collective and you'll
be taking care of a lot of children yeah
but like back it no no no in like olden
times you wouldn't be certain that is
your child
you're right they wouldn't be certain
and that's why that's that's why men
don't like hoes that's why they're
repulsed by girls that sleep around is
because they want to make sure that kid
is theirs
and that's an advantage you want to give
your resources to someone that's
actually yours yes because like in the
past and you really wouldn't know
exactly in nature like that's why in
nature like you wouldn't we didn't have
paternity tests till the last hundred
years and so that's why men don't like
girls that have high body counts or have
slept around they can't even help it
it's just natural to them because they
don't want to pass on resources to
another man's kids there was also a
study that came out that showed that um
they were trying to find out why does it
take so many attempts for humans to
impregnate each other whilst and the
animal came when it's like one to three
times and they said that the reason why
men need to have sex with women so much
is to create that pair bond so by having
sex repeatedly the woman gets more
attached to the guy which and the game
gets more attached to the woman which
makes him more likely to stand up to
stay around and provide resources for
the kid instead of just run around
so it actually is actually built into us
to pair one and stay with one partner
women release that hormone like we
whether or not yeah whether or not you
might be like yeah I'm a girl I can
sleep around and whatnot biologically
when you're having sex or whatnot your
brain is releasing that that bonding
hormones yeah I don't know what the
woman is yeah
you Bond through like like or orgasm
that's why like you have the term
dicmatized yeah and like why like girls
will go back to the best sex of their
life
like over I mean how many girls do you
know that like as soon as their
relationship's done they run back to the
same Acts
the Environmental
huh so it goes the environment where
they recycle
yeah
about body counting it
it's a smart way to to keep your body
count low but still get what you need
though really yeah
that's cool it's a smart way to go about
it
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats for a
second
um guys thank you so much for the
donations
um all super chats are going towards
getting blessing an 8K camera
um basically I want to see I want you
guys to see the freckles on my skin when
we stream so
so I'm send donations it really helps um
all donations really help with that okay
so mgtow by Logic
women demand the best men and complain
they're being asked to settle but if
you're only with
but if you're only with a man better
than you hypergamy then by definition he
is settling not you women day up all the
time and cry about it
clowns
um I ask AB
dul Rahman I learned the other day that
the DNA of other men stays in I learned
the other day the DNA of the man stays
in the woman seven years after
childbirth Clifford remember modern
women are not submissive at all Deo
Jeremy Meeks going to date lizzo more
kayatch I know a lot of women who find
Billy Bob very hot you guys find Billy
Boba is that the guy that was dead yeah
I think he's handsome oh yeah not now
but like back in the day yeah I might
have to look can we can we put him up
yeah can we can we put Billy Bob on the
screen like with Angelina Jolie yeah
let's see I don't
know who's you guys a celebrity crush
Angelina Jody well you like girls more
than guys no I think clothes smash your
past Billy Bob yeah Billy Bob smash your
pass
I'd say pass smash smash and that in
that moment in that time
that guy's attractive you know what
though when I said when like a medium
guy has got like a pretty woman on his
uh arm it makes other girls more like
what's going on oh yeah yeah something
going on that we don't know about yes
don't don't tell the guys that
I love that in college okay
um modern women's self-worth is
hyperinflated the only way to fight this
inflation is the same way you deal with
the economy men need to tighten up their
wallets and stop shrimping
um Christopher what about ism is the new
church of modern women they'll argue
that sharks are oppressing them because
they saw a woman and and get a woman get
eaten in the movie Jaws
um The Savvy ninja legit ratings for the
show ratings equals looks energy and
potential from the furthest from Pearl
to the closest
um 7.5
6.8 6.9 Eddie is a 6.3 I didn't catch
the ladies names in the beginning no
simp no hate make big towel by Logic
that is pretty decent like panel to be
honest but
I mean they usually call people you know
it's pretty high for the ratings they'll
give sometimes make chat by Logic having
to force reality onto people who lie to
your face all day is exhausting it's why
Le judicial workers are so stressed
women should have to pay men one dollar
up for every word they speak to make
listening to their lies bearable
um
Mr Brownie
anyone that thinks average woman
actually anyone that anyone think that
average women who consider themselves 10
10s are actually projecting their desire
to have a man because subconsciously
they know the only thing that can the
only thing that can treat a five like a
ten is a man Christopher sir Dak Pearl
can any of the women on the panel
explain the difference between
confidence and arrogance the distinction
has been programmed out of modern women
Joseph metzer Metzler 10 is not perfect
it's being in the top one percent being
introspective is not something most
people are willing or able to do for men
confidence derives from competence for
women it comes from affirmation Clifford
range Pearl can can you get a I feel jar
for the panel
for anyone on the panel who says I feel
mgtel by Logic confidence isn't
confidence if it's a lie
okay
I have another clip for us to react to
so pull up click clip number three
all right blessing what whoa whoa
oh move the bottle yeah just before
you're okay
okay oh this is what I was talking about
earlier we started from the beginning if
you don't mind blessing
these two I think like women are just
fat today yeah which is nice which women
like which most women like to be fat
rather than slim now do you think they
like I don't think they like you yeah
they like they like okay a big butt with
a small waist that's not true yeah
but this one here she's got a great
shape she's she's got big butts small
waist naturally is is it depends on your
state and I think you wouldn't see it
but I mean most women like to be
bigger now nowadays rather than deemed
skinny maybe they pretend they're happy
because there's body positivity I'm
happy big girl's life is just amazing
it's been as big as Lisa or yeah
she happy okay let me ask you let me let
me she's making money one to ten what do
you rank lizzo one to ten ten uh no
based on money
okay okay
look one at a time I'm so confident
she's so comfortable do you really think
she's cries on Instagram live oh I don't
know that much about her I just know I
see her
do you genuinely okay do you genuinely
think she's happy at like 300 pounds how
could one be happy does she not look
happy I think she looks the surprise I
don't know her personally so I but from
what I can see
looks wise
social media is very deceptive yes okay
okay so so one to ten you would trade
trade your body with hers
[Laughter]
gotcha
okay
let me let me just let me finish this
like why do you lie no no let me let me
finish let me finish you said she had a
good figure yeah dude she would be
offended if you said she looks like
lizzo would you be offended if I said
you look fat
but do you think that's what it is she's
a good figure because she's so cute
who's skinny women trying to be nice but
lizard than a really skinny skinny woman
yeah
but it's the same thing he's like really
skinny okay I would
no I think if she wanted to she'd do it
she had those she was on Tick Tock like
on the treadmill
I don't you see a whole different side
of words
I do have a question you gave her a 10.
what's your metric because she's
confident with it
anybody that's confident I think yeah
women race with feeling not logic
it comes with with how you feel that's
what I can see I was big and I liked it
but it's a big small what made you like
it because I was different and I
couldn't I don't go gym I hate gym I
hate anything healthy I eat everything
not healthy but I liked it then I like
it now I and I'm very confident do you
not think there's Universal standards of
beauty so when everyone walks into the
room where everyone can kind of okay
when everyone walks into the room you
don't think everyone has a general
wait blessing can you finish the
sentence and then and then you can pause
it
perception of who's more beautiful and
less beautiful
so I meant like for her response too
sorry I don't know these days no I'm not
I'm not talking about these days I mean
in general well before
and okay even even take us in the room
you don't think most of us like they
could say who's more beautiful and less
beautiful and I'm not I'm not trying to
put us against each other I'm not saying
to be rated but like I'm saying like you
don't think in general you know who the
pretty friend in your friend group is I
think what she's doing okay
foreign
why is it so hard for women to admit
that lizzo is not a 10.
and why don't we see the same body
positivity for men
it's all about the women's empowerment
like women want to feel so empowered
free I guess gears on the under the
patriarchy that anything goes there is
this women can do no wrong in anyone's
eyes you can be fat you can be whole you
can do this you can slap up slap up a
guy don't matter as long as you're a
woman
everything you do get Sublime
so now you just delete yourselves just
lie to each other
at your own detriment because to say
someone like lizzo is attractive and
healthy and homegirl said myself like I
don't like gym I don't like to do
anything healthy that's someone to run
away from
straight away but again to say that you
might be misogynistic or blah blah blah
like anything a woman does nowadays is
yeah we're like even when talking about
uh guys and relationships it's always I
feel like it's filled with excuses like
oh no he does like you it's just he does
like you but he's no he just don't like
you you just need to be straight up
about certain things
um it's a bit harsh telling your friends
I'll uh you're overweight
no that's that's actually a lot easier
than saying um you're ugly but I think
yeah definitely yeah you can change your
weight you can't change if your face
looks like like looks like you got
smashed in with a baseball bat
what do you think Tiana I don't know I
feel like like you said like
it's easier to judge once like to judge
yourself than to judge someone else
because then you're kind of like you're
projecting what you view as Beauty onto
somebody else which isn't really
important I don't know I feel like it's
a very uncomfortable place to sit in but
you don't think there's subjective
standards of beauty no I do believe in
them okay I do think that like a lot of
models are really tall they're very thin
uh it depends where you are but like the
certain metrics that we can use or even
if we take like modeling out of it like
there's certain girls that men find more
attractive
because yeah it's not always necessarily
the models you know what I mean like
there's just some girls that are like
imagine yeah yeah I think we know I feel
like there's an unspoken rule like I do
think like we know who the pretty friend
is you know but then why do girls try
and take out the
the general View and try to make it
based on the individual because you'll
be like for me or just that when
generally speaking you know whether the
song is attractive or not so why do you
feel like why do women take out the the
more objective View and try to make it
subjective as possible I think maybe I'm
just gonna go for what I I think very
it's a very feminine to be
um empathetic and maybe compassionate
and
being 100 direct and honest and like
just laying down the fact is a very
masculine trait so I'm not going to go
to these two girls and tell them that
they look a certain way I'm not going to
rate them objectively from my
perspective because I just like to what
end what does that bring either one of
us here you ask the question someone
asked you a question though so why would
you lie I'm not gonna lie but I just
feel like okay after the show yeah
if you say that it's very masculine to
just uh just you know give a very just a
fact yeah and then say it's feminine to
be empathetic you can you can you know
kindly say to somebody the truth I've
done it so many times I think there's a
different dog
character is ugly if they are they're
not we're not asking about character you
look straight at your face I know but
okay if we're talking about weight I did
have a friend who's having difficulty
putting up having a child and I told her
it's because you're fat
and I'm her closest friend and she took
it and she but because of I
I'm not just some strangers like saying
yeah you're fine yeah go girl and stuff
I apologize but um I I told her no it's
because you're fat
and you have to take responsibility I as
a friend I'm not gonna sit here like I
have my own life and my time I'm giving
it to you if you're gonna sit there
telling me the whole the same circular
argument that's actually disrespectful
to me like if you're if you really
generally want to get pregnant sort your
diet out and now guess what she's doing
great
that's it so she's better looking now
would you say now that she's lost the
weight the objective was to get pregnant
and her weight was a massive thing but
it was I mean that's actually that's the
way that her weight loss has helped her
and the bonus is that she's actually
attractive so the goal wasn't to get
attractive the goal was to get healthy
and you know by a result she became
attractive because she is healthy does
that make sense yeah and I told her I'm
a friend I would consider myself quite
feminine and a woman and I told you
you're fat you're ugly and I think it's
the human thing I get I think we get too
caught up with masculine energy feminine
energy what's human to do and to look
out for something I think um women are
kind of more socialized to kind of beat
around the bush you know what I mean
like to be coy
um it's kind of rewarded when women were
like oh look they're not as like oh I
want this this and this I think women
are rewarded in romantic relationships
and friendships and relationships with
other people in society so if you know
that why would you still purposely like
or willingly do it will in feet so you
just said that um women are kind of
socialized to behave a certain type of
way and you know that way you're
socialized is negative in terms of
creating a better outcome for all but
yet you still sat here and still went
I think I I still do this because
obviously that's what I'm used to I find
it extremely uncomfortable to go to
someone and call them fat or call them
ugly if I would ask you so if I said am
I fat and I was visibly fat you'd find
it uncomfortable to be honest with me
and be like you know what I would find
that really uncomfortable for me I feel
like say the words outside out loud like
I can think certain things in my mind my
mind but to directly say to someone
straight up like I think you're ugly
especially if it's in negative terms
it'll be very difficult for me so we're
friends yeah so if I said I said if I
gained that's if I gained 50 pounds yeah
and I said
did I get fat this is different because
you would you because you're Pearl yeah
how can you handle anything she wants
you to be so direct but had German Au
pairs grown up to German nanny so I know
she can handle it so okay
okay we're standing with Germany
nannies
[__]
it also you have to have
um a bit of tact and I feel like you
need to gauge the person as well but
let's let's role play okay oh okay
okay okay okay okay
set the scene
I just got rejected for the 10th time in
a row
um and he said it was because I'm too
thick did I did I get fat I know I ate
one or two brownies
okay or ten what am I am I fat what
should be am I I don't know I haven't I
haven't I don't weigh myself
do you have scales at home no okay I
have scales I avoid them like the plague
no it just gives me anxiety I can't cut
the skill okay
interesting what do you think your BMI
is
I don't know I just I don't even know
how BMI works I just I think it's like a
scale that's like not real so I feel
like they just make that up you know
doctors to be mean okay do you think
you're overweight
I mean
I question it a little bit but that's
why I came to you to get the truth
okay
you see how this is really hard for me
you see how like I went to every other
option 101 of beating around the bush I
was doing so well I came with the beer
model she could have got on the scales
it could have worked out together let me
let me try it with Eddie let me try with
Eddie
you can like all right
so so this is you know I'm not you know
I'm just like
shaking all over there yeah Eddie it's
been a minute since I've seen you how
are you doing I'm good are you telling
me what I'm good how are you I'm good
I'm good
um
anyways I I I was walking here and
someone called me a whale a whale yeah
yeah did I did I get fat I ain't gonna
lie when I did see you you was looking a
bit more chunky than last time I see you
still but
look so right the cheeks are grown okay
okay so just chunky I'm not I'm not fat
no I ain't gonna lie you put a mad
weight in it like drop a few drop a
little something something in you mad
wait what does that mean am I am I fat
you're fat
he kind of beat around the bush too I
didn't like the way you said it though
because it's playful like you was very
playful with it you were just like
you're fat and ugly yeah that's pretty
crazy
no no okay everybody scroll back and
then did I quote unquote she said fat
and ugly I feel like no I think I think
me me not you I don't know no I I didn't
you can find out
if I said she's fat and ugly I said she
became attractive because she's because
she's healthy does that means she would
have stayed ugly no but you said like
um I think you said like you quoted
yourself he was like no you said you
think you have to say I know I know oh
okay look back okay can we bet some
money or something
okay but now I'm playful with it
I guess I guess I respect you actually
oh thank you because it's good to have a
friend like you that will call it
straight even if it hurts you you're the
most respected friend I have to say the
thing is that there needs to be context
okay so this she tells me this over and
over again and I try to you know in a
polite way and it's like um the thing is
like I said I am not my existence isn't
to just the pacify you you know and if
you're saying that oh you know I have
this issue and my weight is this and
everything and I was like you know what
I have to cut this crap you are fat and
her radical acceptance is the most
powerful thing that's when change
actually ensued she got healthy and she
had a baby that was the objective so so
much uh problems were avoided with me
just being honest with her and if she's
an adult she's gonna take that I think
in order to suddenly forget who I am 100
good friends 100 agree with you I think
there's a way of like doing it with tax
like you can be playful about it but if
you're honest and real this person it
won't affect your relationship wasn't
mean I was like you're fat you're fat
that's it I feel like if you're honest
with someone and factual with a person a
relationship cannot be destroyed I feel
like if someone's real with you and
tells you something straight
if it was a real friendship I don't
think would affect it it's why you don't
do it for fear of losing that
relationship with the person the the
reason I don't do it is that I find it
extremely uncomfortable I don't think
I'm I'm not used to doing it I don't
practice it
people to be honest with you
maybe not no oh you're lucky to lie to
you man them sliding them deals and sell
dreams no because I'll believe those
dreams oh yeah and I don't see a problem
with that like think about it
hypothetically let's say if I think that
um
I'm like really crazy amazing like
really really beautiful and someone's
telling me dreams and I believe the
dreams he sells me happily ever after in
my delusion oh so why pop the bubble so
question are you cool with getting
cheated on if you never find out
oh that's a hot one I don't want to ever
be quoted on this but I feel like
actually let me let me drink first let
me have you seen that have you seen that
Tick Tock that it's like when you catch
your billionaire husband and then having
an affair an affair and you're like ah I
didn't see anything like because if you
never find out it doesn't affect you and
you're just believing the lies
um I think that's the thing after he
sold you to dreams then what was his
intention of selling new dreams to he
Wonder wife you he just wanted to wife
you and have side pieces
if he wanted to wife me and he didn't
want to have side pieces then I'd be
okay no no I said he's lying he's
telling you the dream as we said
but he's sending a lie
well you wanted you said you said you
like being lied to
you don't bust my bubble yeah nobody
burst my bubbles in if someone's like oh
I find you really attractive and
beautiful like crazy beautiful you're
looking model and I'm like okay I
believe this too I believe this
narrative
that that narrative doesn't have to
involve cheating and if it doesn't why
burst that bubble and maybe okay oh
she's you're you're five you should be
with like a five two you know you know
what a guy can't get with you if he's if
he's approached you like you know what I
think you're all right you're pretty
decent but you know what I like you
anyway you're gonna be like what like
you're not getting a chance unless
you're obsessed with me unless I'm like
the best thing you've seen like that's
it there's also that as well so you
because there's always someone that will
treat you that way yeah there's always
someone that'll treat you what way
um I don't know like treat you like
they really value you like if you tell
someone like yeah you're okay
it just seems like do you think we like
the guys that put us on pedestals I
think we really enjoy that really I
think that gets guys laid no no I feel
like women enjoy being the receiving end
of being put on this pedestal yeah like
I I like I enjoy it women have like a
group of men who work just for attention
all the guys that feed them constant
attention that make them feel validated
yeah
that's the friend zone that's the guys
in the DMs I don't like none of these
guys but they make me feel good about
myself yeah the ones that don't have a
chance but it's just like there you go
yeah thanks anyway yeah if I wanted to I
could but
do you think guys can move out of that
zone out of the friend zone once they're
in it I think if a woman has decided
something she won't change her mind I
don't know you know I see a lot of guys
Escape it I think there's a frame I
think there's there's a particular type
of guy who is this very very patient in
it yeah
cool you've been friends with this girl
she's going through breakup off the
breakup because you're always making bad
decisions you just have to be there at
the right time
listen you put them there in it it's
more of a long-term investment strategy
yeah but like okay like let's say okay
that does happen they hook up one time
and she wakes up
improved
wow you you need to
need to sketch from Chris Rock when he
says why women keep a lot of like guy
friends and stuff because they're all
seriously
yeah
it's such a funny skin yeah yeah we can
we can we'll give him a second but yeah
ultimately there comes a time where a
woman has to choose between what they
always go for which I think is probably
not the best
um partner for the year it's probably
just the like maybe like the bad but you
know how like women always like yeah men
are trash men are trust but it's like no
you need to change what you go for
there's a difference between arousal and
attraction attraction is like the guy
that you could take home to Mom and Dad
and he's like the good boyfriend like
you're attracted him from that way and
arousal's like the bad boy and I think
most girls want like a mix of the two if
they can but but typically like there's
no mix it's usually one or the other you
think so
yeah I mean like I don't think most
most like stable guys also have that bad
boy side to them and I think if you find
one you you try to hold on to them yeah
because you know what they Pro those
stable guys provide peace and obviously
peace doesn't mean continuous uh yeah
stimulation but you're aroused by the
drama yeah yeah because yeah and I don't
think girls this is a much more honest
like panel because girls like we don't
like to admit that like I meant like
okay like why why do girls okay
wow girls like getting cheated on on
some level
it's not it's not fun but like why is
every girl obsessed with the ex that
cheated on her
that's always the one she goes back to
yeah and I feel like you should when
you're going into something new you
shouldn't be talking about oh my God
like my ex done this and that to me you
need to no one needs to know where you
wasn't valued you need to be completely
that's just so healthy and just really
just listen this is what I expect that's
it and you think less but regardless of
my feelings I need to I need to leave
you need to put your feelings aside but
then girls also go for guys that they
know are likely to cheat on them so
there's the ex who cheated excitement
and there's the new guy he's just like
you know this guy's probably gonna cheat
on me but in your head like I can change
him I can make him a better or maybe
maybe he wanted to be like I'm me
because you always go like what value do
you bring well at me so that's and
that's the thing like because women are
kind of narcissistic because they like
like we think we can we're the one
that's gonna change him but it's like
there's only one there's only one
there's a million there's a new girl
turning 22 every day
um
okay we're gonna watch Chris Rock
this is
um
set
oh yeah it's a five you can do the whole
thing you can do the whole thing
you've been enjoyment yes
oh my God it's true though I mean go up
to a guy friend and just be like listen
like
I need something from you but I don't
know like what are you gonna do if I put
on you right now what are you gonna are
you gonna tell me no
exactly he's been you over
literally you're slamming cheeks ASAP
have you guys ever had a guy make it out
of the friend zone
um there's been
I mean are they really in the friend
zone if they're really in the friend
zone then I'll be like uh what are you
doing but then if they if it's like a
half-hearted friend it's like a willday
won't they it's so you guys had a work
husband before okay would you
it's like the person you hang out with
at work all the time it's like the
opposite but you've never done anything
yeah like I think that's more I think
that's more likely to happen than a
friend zone okay would you agree I feel
like for girls there's three categories
there's like absolutely yes absolutely
no and maybe yeah yeah well that covers
everything
the absolute maybe would be
um like like the maybes are like oh he's
kind of cute but
yeah it's like a butt where the yes is
like yeah that's what he's talking about
where at some way at some point he took
a wrong turn and landed in the friend
zone she's like you were going in the
right direction when you've done
something that didn't quite tick the box
so you're a maybe there's a chance one
day in under the right circumstances but
for now you can chill there I got all
I've got better options available right
now yeah so I can put you the back
burner interesting and guys will wait as
well so 100 it's crazy that goes away
you find that quite they're not waiting
but they're not waiting they're doing
their thing yeah it's just they're not
opportunistic so it's like it's that
cool if if I got a girl I'm serious
about like okay I want you and I know
you're not going to give it up to me
easy I might still be doing it in that
stuff breaking it down little by little
I'm still acting breaking it down I'm
breaking it down just chipping away
slowly but I'm still at it cook on
shoulders like you know what I'm saying
this men like that sorry do you think
men like
um moving from the friend zone to
something more I think that's more it's
the most satisfying that's a proud
moment is that more satisfying than like
hooking up with somebody you meet at the
club
yeah yeah yeah
it's like in sales when you've got those
sales reference when you've got them
deals that stretch for ages and you
fight you can you close the deal and you
close it you're like oh my God I closed
the door it's gas you want to go out on
a Friday night drink with the boys do
whatever I hear some guys say that
they'll get like like resentful in a way
because they're like I waited all that
time for that yeah because they built it
up in their heads because they wanted to
keep grafting it never lives up to
expectations that's why now I probably
like the chase more than the outcome I
agree with you I like the chase more
than the outcome
interesting no like examine you're
seeing someone like let's say work has
been hypothetical scenario and it's like
a will they like will we won't we that's
more
exciting then like if we just date
straight away and I know okay he's
definitely attracted to me he definitely
wants to see me as a girlfriend then if
it's like I don't know so is that why
people like cheats what do you mean like
if they get comfortable with somebody
and then that's why they want to go
chase somebody because you've got that
now but I think it's the difference
between
um after sex are you cuddling or are you
not
what do you mean right but as in uh the
chase now you've got you've fulfilled a
Chase uh what comes next are you gonna
are you still interested or was it just
about to chase if it was just about to
chase now he's got what he's won so
he's gonna bounce I think from the
female side
um part of the attraction of a guy is
the mystery is about trying to
understand and find out about this guy
so regards it an element of War a bit of
mystery about him he's this fascinating
interesting thing that you want to
acquire I think in that scenario once
you've discovered what that mystery is
so I I have sex with him excuse me and
then the the error the air of mystery is
gone and you're no longer interested I
think that's true I feel like if
someone's like mysterious or there's
like an Arab mystery to them I don't
feel like
hugging up with them one time would mean
that like I'm not interested in them
anymore no maybe that's just my
perspective of that from The Thrill of
the chase perspective
because most women like a guy who's
mysterious like a guy who did like it's
a hard not to crack that thing they'll
have to just know that
I think a lot of women like that like I
only have access to this man not like in
like a possessive way but like he's only
showing this side to me like a lot of
women appreciate that and I feel like
when that is revealed then I guess that
law and excitement yeah that's why when
a guy women want a gather to be more
emotional stuff like that and then you
get so many years and then they get on
it then then they get turned off by him
hmm
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats
um thank you guys for all the donations
all the donations are going towards
getting blessing an 8K camera I think we
can swing it this month um it's actually
really cool because we're gonna start
um bringing in some other creators and
helping them build channels so
um we're gonna announce next week I'm
gonna give you guys the link to Auntie's
new channel um and there might be one or
two more which is really exciting I'll
do a round of applause Round of Applause
um okay so I'm gonna read these uh
Christopher cerdack as Rolla tomasi has
said for decades if a woman makes you
wait for sex the sex is never worth the
wait it's just a consolation prize for
both of you mgtow by Logic a woman's BC
equals how many bodies does a woman need
for for your friends to call her a [__]
minus one you're welcome boys
um came all parasite and organism living
in on or with another organism in order
to obtain nutrients grow or multiply in
a state that directly or indirectly
harms the host you got me fellas yeah
wrong the harpooner the hormone oxytocin
allows pear bonding which
allows to pair bonding women's release
woman's brain release it during sex and
child's worth having many partners
Alters the mechanism in the woman's
brain that's why more Partners hurts
women
um Clifford range if the truth doesn't
hurt then it's not the truth that they
want to be lied to but complain about
men lying to them hey Ken um
memogolu it's funny it's funny and
tragic to see the double standards
please keep up the great content on Brit
Cormier Pearl I bet if you put up pics
of men there but I bet if you put up if
you put pics pictures of men up there
these women could rate them without an
issue faster if you put up pictures with
their Hyatt woman can somehow slice
through all the BS when it comes to
reading men's looks however reading
other women is well it's how they feel
mgtow by Logic stop lying lizzo isn't in
the room she can't say she can't hear
you say it she's fat just say it silent
Observer There are rules to objective
reality delusion is simply a smoke
screen towards the truth feelings are
fleeting chaos and chaos like depending
on the present circumstances facts may
be painful but they provide feedback
about the physical reality make tell by
Logic I'm not going to lie that was
Elias God damn it stop lover for one
hero to all the inflation of women's
value is so bad that a basic teacher can
have a pet man named Fluffy and another
man she has sex with that live in the
same house mgtow by Logic just stop
lying God damn it we can't have real
conversations without all the lying
lying is ruining society and the ability
for men and women to form relationships
stop it Christopher sir that can the can
the girl in the middle complete a
sentence without using the word but
lover for hero all men care about women
so much that will devalue ourselves to
make you happy majority of men male
Heroes get belittled Nerf bum Downs for
the hero Ends mgtel by Logic women
demand the best man and complain they're
being asked to settle but if you're only
with one man but if you're only with a
man better than you hypergony is by
definition settling women date up all
the time and and still cry about it
clowns
um let's do the last clip
uh blessing thank you
the
oh yeah this this actually had nothing
to do with the topic I just thought this
was entertaining
wait what yeah this is
oh no
is it quite graphic no no
no yeah I just was like this is nuts
no girls are on smoke you know but that
is a bit crazy though
which which part of it all right holding
someone over
wait look at that Freeze Frame wait wait
wait no wait that's an old man with a
cane no
oh my God Jordan for two people
well you might have to replay this
though
you can do it again I don't know if he
died or not it does it say in the
comments does it say in the description
blessing did he die
oh he passed away did they run over
anyone else
oh wow so the other person died too two
murders
but do you think that is the related
with the whole situation or do you think
she actually has like a mental illness
excuses no because that's not normal
that's like do you tend to happen I mean
do you think if the roles were reversed
we'd be asking that question if it was a
man who ran over a woman
I would say it's like no he would need a
really good lawyer to come up with that
argument what would you argument uh that
if he had a mental illness mental
problem because to really you know
bring back people to not be uh to be
impartial and not be gender biased
because it happens like it doesn't
matter what we feel it's it's definitely
women unfortunately get away with it a
lot more than men does it say what her
like she gets sentenced
um I don't know
we'll face the charge so
um it says Chapman will face one charge
of aggravated murder two counts of
murder two counts of felonies
felonies assault one count of attempted
murder and one count of endangering
children were the kids in the car oh
goodness or maybe the kids were nearby
on August 31st Chapman allegedly drove
her car into the father of her child her
intended target also and also hit the 58
year old Christopher Scott who died at
the University of Cincinnati Medical
Center from his injuries Chapman then
got out of the car and began physically
assaulting the man with whom she had an
eight-year-old child an eight-month-old
child that child was inside the vehicle
when Chapman hit two men according to
Heyman County prosecutor Joe Devers
while he was in Kroger she apparently
went through his cell phone and believed
that he had an inappropriate
relationship with her sister and said
deters during a press conference
wcpo.com
come here can we all right you can click
it yeah
click a blessing
so sad
oh
why do women feel Justified
in doing damn near anything when it
comes to a man cheating on them like for
example
um Wendy Williams made a joke about
chopping a man's off
um on national TV and no one cared
um because a girl chopped her um
basically a girl chopped her partner's
like off and
um Wendy Williams basically and said oh
he deserved it
but if the rolls were reversed like a
dude chopped you know our stuff off
it wouldn't be the same
women women get uh less time in prison
usually as well
yeah when it gets to being in charge and
being uh similar crimes yes uh it's like
three times the amount of sentencing for
the same crime yeah and good I think
naturally but just because physically
we're more vulnerable I mean I don't
think we I don't think it should be it's
not it's not solicited at all I mean it
a crime is a crime
man or woman whatever but um
it's
physically we're more vulnerable so it's
a bit like
oh if he's cheated on me like
will I hit him
if I do like
so like not me that's not I don't know
me personally yeah
if you get if your boyfriend cheated on
you how would you react
I think women we have an upper hand in
more
um
have it created more mind [__] like
emotionally mentally like letting them
using your words so would you be would
you be spiteful enough no best friend or
something no no no no that that's like
that's like scoring our own goal I want
that that's no I would probably do
something worse no do something that
would actually let him know yeah you
[__] up okay like leave and cut
contact men I feel like men they learn
through through pain or men learn
through absence if someone's got access
to me he's
realistically is thinking yeah I know I
know I heard they start the other but
rather like I'm still trying to right
now no you need to cut all contacts and
that's it you need to put him on timeout
and that's with your absence is when a
guy will really feel like whoa what am I
doing like I feel I feel like she's not
talking to me she's not talking to me oh
my God like it's real this time she's
really pissed off
yeah
but I think in reference to the question
I think
this is this is the this is how
successful feminine feminism has been in
society and it's that kind of century
order the society has now become
part of it is down to the like the
feminist agenda but it's also down to
men overcompensating for what women
perceive the patriarchy have been so I
think a lot of women are unappreciative
of what men have done to propel Society
into where it currently is so feminism
has managed to Garner quite a lot of
strength in terms of changing people's
social perceptions to how men and women
do with each other and in order for men
not to be considered misogynistic or I
guess the ostracizum society they
overcompensate for a lot of the things
that women do so a lot of things be
overlooked like I talk like I remember
bringing up a story in the podcast
before about when I was like s Aid and
it was funny to everyone
but if like if and it was funny to me as
well don't get me wrong because I never
felt at fret like it is what it is but
flip that over and put that same
scenario but as a woman it's game over
to basically give context like a woman
like ripped open my Robin and one bit my
chest was my Willy's all out and blah
blah blah but like if I was to go to
woman in the night out a bus band of a
rip open a dress and then my friend
sakatiki yeah it's going left no no no I
agree I agree that this should be taken
like they're both the same degree of
like they're both the same thing like
when one Jenner does one thing and the
same gender does the same thing with sa
it's both should be taken like with the
same gravity I feel so I think a lot of
women say that though but I think in in
reality I don't believe a lot of you
I know what you want to say here you
want to say like women don't see to the
same gravity but I also feel like
I don't want to like make men the victim
again in this situation but I do feel
like men do enable certain things like
that because you see a lot of times on
like Twitter or online that you see that
men like lose their virginity to really
older women
um but in the present when that happened
a lot of the friends these male friends
were enabling that like oh like you've
seen a MILF you're doing this and this
and this and they don't actually
recognize you know within their group of
men that what they was doing or what
they were enabling was actually
something really messed up I mean you
don't you don't think women kind of do
the same thing when we're twerking
online when like any grown man can see
that or like your 15 year old dressed in
damn near nothing what do you think
you're attracting
I don't know what you're asking me so
I'm saying wouldn't you say like women
enable it too
I guess so I guess a certain degree yeah
I guess to a certain degree I'm not
saying that women don't like I'm talking
about them the subjective male
experience because you're talking about
your essay experience I'm talking to how
um it just comes under that category it
comes under that category
um but like I feel like um with the Mad
experience and things like that happen
like sexually as well I feel like
sometimes the male Community also does
enable certain things by making certain
things
um elusive like I want to date an older
woman I want to have these experiences
like you'll see like men will try to get
into clubs really young I try to go to
certain parties really young because
they want to meet older women or I don't
know see I don't think the problem is
that men enable it because I think for
the most part it's it's weirdly a
privileged position to be in considering
that most men don't have access to sex
in the first place so it's being a
position where women want you that much
they're willing to do that to you is
probably a privileged position for a man
so I wouldn't say most men complain
about that I think the problem is is
that when women seek their so-called
equality who then don't want to live by
equal standards that's going to become
problematic so the only reason I bring
up that point is because when women talk
about equality you only speak in terms
of double standards that suit you and
when it doesn't suit you you no longer
want it anymore
it depends on what topics though because
we're equal but men are women not about
men I mean as humans we are but men and
women are different we have different
needs like even with this Modern Woman
women thing like I think is I don't
think more and more women should try to
become more masculine I think women need
to embrace uh their own femininity and
understand the power in that instead of
trying to be this you know what your
go-getter I'm gonna be a go get Resort
I'm going to take on your role as well
like no we have our separate we have our
separate roles in the world uh whether
or not people wanna
uh understand that or not because yeah
we're equal but to a certain extent it
doesn't mean you're more important I'm
more important but just unfortunately we
have different roles like they say uh
women and children are the only people
that are loved unconditionally whereas
men they love conditioning on what you
can do on the action you take on how you
built like you said we just have I guess
we're born of like indefinite value
whereas Men You're judged on like who
are you what have you done what can you
provide etc etc
do you think that will stay the same
though because I feel like it's like
that because Society is built in a way
where traditionally men were in the
workforce and traditionally member
seniors providers
so member scenes as a means to work when
someone's a means to work they're a
means to provide that's why they were
loved conditionally and now more women
are entering the workforce I think that
could happen to us too so yeah we're not
expected to do things as well I think
men are just seen as Expendable in
society that's why they do all the hard
jobs that's why they're the ones sent to
war their bodies are going to be on the
line when if we go to war like I think
no matter even if women are in the
workforce what are we doing we're not
doing the hard jobs
yeah like like you you have more
testosterone you can build muscles this
that the other we can't we have other
uses but I think in terms of your
question you need to whatever energy
you're giving out you need to understand
your own energy is it feminine masculine
whatever regardless of your sex you need
to know what energy
is yours and that's the only way you'll
be able to excel in what you do and also
attract the opposite uh partner that you
need well based on that logic we're not
equal I think we can strive for balance
because obviously there's there's things
that you're better around there's things
that I'm better at that makes us balance
so what what are men good at and what
are women better at like can you give
some stereotypical like gender skills
gendered skills men are better with
things women are better with people
okay so like with that logic it would
make a lot of sense for men to be sent
to war because they're better at those
kind of things and then we make a lot
more sense for men to be leaders but
we're just not
we will be the Medics like like women to
be commanding and ruling and like
delegating tasks are meant to be doing
those tasks no but that's a cognitive
dissonance then because you're saying
that
women are better with working with
people so like directing people telling
people to do things are better are doing
okay I should say women are more
interested in doing jobs that have to
deal with people but when it comes to
leadership women don't excel in
leadership like men do oh so sorry can
you just sorry because because you can
work you can work in people with people
as the checkout person at a grocery
store
like like leadership leadership no but
I'm saying like leadership and working
with people are two different sectors
but like you said like you said men are
good they're like the hottest jobs
Plumbing electricity like everything
yeah if we look at men in that way that
that's their skill set
um in places like War it would make
sense that the women would be
controlling controlling and organizing
the war and that the men would actually
go out and fight but they wouldn't know
the all the logistics they have to be a
soldier themselves no no no no like when
people go to war the soldier doesn't
know everything they get given commands
there's someone that opens from a
general human from somebody who's got
experience and actually yeah in the
battlefield no no most generals have
never been on the battlefield so how do
they get what they get the normal they
normally go go to university they get
degrees in like math
that's different there's different sort
of ranks so there's like if you're
talking about SAS then everyone's going
to be out in combat but if you're
talking about things like large Wars and
large things are organized by large
organizations like um like I'm let's say
like
you said the American Army it's not
going to be just organized by just
soldiers not everyone in that Army will
go and fight there'll be people that
will organize things they'll be
um intelligence surveillance things like
that people that collect information and
use it people that have like master's
degrees phds like maths right and
understands it I see I see your logic I
see a logic but where it's flawed is
that and this is from you can read you
know what have you heard the book
sapiens by Yovan this is out of Sapien
so in that book he talks about
um why female lit societies didn't do as
well as they should have done if your
examples were correct and they said that
when it comes to
um organizing groups men are better when
it comes to large scale whilst women are
better when it comes to small so small
social factions where it's like mothers
and the children when it when it large
scale you need to be able to yeah yeah
and men are much better at providing
that myth than women are so by that same
logic men are still better at leadership
than women will because women are better
and small scales not large girls I
understand what you're saying I was like
let me move this down
um but I feel like what you're saying
applies
um to all genders so
um when you're with a large group of
people you need a common mess and I
don't think that's like
I don't think that's dependent on gender
and like Paul said before history tells
us it is though because again that book
the pictures that what the best the most
optimal function in society is what
lives the toe to tell so if women were
just as good at providing myth then it
would be massive female-led societies
that had their own let's just say like
they had their own continent that would
be doing their thing but they don't and
they had the opportunity to do so I'm
quoting the same book as you I'm quoting
the same example and a similar example
from this book and it says there's a
cognitive dissonance where
women have the skills to lead but
they're just not put in that leadership
role and then I have the typical skills
but then wouldn't you say they're not
good at it like I didn't say they
weren't good at it I'm just saying that
women also have the quality I'm saying
like like okay
I could say oh I'm really good at
volleyball but if I never played and
never did it well then like like okay I
could say redheads are better at
volleyball
but then if redheads never play
volleyball and never do it well you
can't say redheads are better at
volleyball so saying like women are
better leaders but if they don't oh if
you use the example okay I'm good at
volley
um I'm gonna be good at volleyball but
you've never played and I say but
Pearl's a good athlete she'd probably be
good at volleyball that's probably
probably what I'm trying to say is that
women have the capacity to do these
things because they have these skills
from other places so they have people
skills they have listening skills they
can be quite organized they have a lot
of stamina for certainly I don't know
because I think the best leaders are
better they're not really the best
listeners they tell you what to do
I think the best leader is someone that
can is that was respected by other
people but can also understand what this
needs to be done now they can prioritize
this is a super chat it says the best
leaders are those who are not not only
good with people but they but they must
be able to have an
arbitrary or an impartial view on any
given Topic in Conflict which best
facilitates the larger good men are more
logical and empirical versus women
so it's just like yeah I feel like women
can prioritize
as well and if like that's a key
feeling it I feel like I feel like I
feel like it's all for you guys it's a
subjective opinion I know but I just
think like every I've always preferred
like male bosses because we get
emotional we get in our feelings with
stuff you know yeah women women and
women women okay that's true that is
true I don't really get on with the
women bosses but you know what
yeah at least you're honest about it
yeah when things are hard you you want a
man beside you that can make all the
hard decisions obviously a woman can as
well both both can do whatever it just
depends on you but large scale yeah like
I feel like what you're saying is like
really correlational like
but there's been studies to prove it
because they didn't did the Scandinavian
study on on what women do when given
more opportunity to pick what they want
and it turns out that when women are
given opportunities they don't really
pick stuff I've seen those studies I'm
just saying that women have the capacity
yeah but they also did um a TV show
where they put like 15 men and 15 women
on like two islands and they had to like
figure out how to survive and like by
the first day like the men had figured
out how to get water how to hunt for
food they'd given everybody rolls and
like the women almost died three times
and the producers had to come in and
help them
the women are probably just talking
about what they're going to do yeah the
men are probably just like right Stacy
Stacy keeps telling me what to do that
[__]
it shows that the more the more
primitive the society the more gender
roles that they are is easily assigned
so the more primitive to society is men
do this so when we do that it's a plane
like we're talking about Society like
you've read the book sapiens like after
the agriculture
so let's talk like if all if we're
hunting
do you really think we'd be so gender
like everyone
go back to that because we'd go for
what's most optimal for survival because
it's not for you to go out and Hunt it's
me no but like wouldn't it be optimal
that we're both huntering and Gathering
it's most optimal that you're at home
pregnant with the babies preparing the
new generation whilst I'm out there
being Expendable bringing home the bacon
yeah like listen I want when I'm in when
I'm going bed I want my man has to go on
I would naturally expect him to sleep on
the side of the door at me closest to
the room that doesn't mean someone's got
something to happen or even just things
like uh you know putting me to the side
of the payment and him walking on the
side of the road
it's not like oh like men are
not important but I don't know I was
like a gentleman that's a lot of things
the first line of protection yeah like I
would just expect that anyway naturally
things like that just seem appealing to
me because just like oh like if
somebody's biological if somebody breaks
in at 3am you would naturally go and who
would naturally cower away not that it's
a bad thing I'm gonna have him the bed
and expect a woman like to come and I
said babes go get that my point is
usually get him usually in a time of
Crisis that's when our natural selves
come out exactly because when it's
everything stable and calm or whatever
we can take have the privilege of saying
hypothetical I I could take on a man
sure and when it actually happens a
perfect example Ukraine is we live in a
modern age people saw Ukraine and if you
saw a tick tock when that was going off
every single feminist was like listen
I'm in the kitchen I didn't want to go
to war yeah literally no I I agree with
you I would never want to actually
engage in a fight on purpose like even
if I was like trained like to the top
level with like all martial arts because
I do train martial arts I still wouldn't
want to pick a fight I would still
always go because why would I choose to
put myself in danger well that's like a
martial art like principle wouldn't it
like to to not deliberately go out
exactly
I wish I could find this video but it
was a video that they showed um they
just went around recording random people
and they asked the men
um do I ask the women first if you had
to pick between you or your husband to
die who would you pick and older women
said to him and then they asked older
men and all the men said me and is this
husband and wife the husband and wife
yeah
ouch
so that's just the perfect example of
society in like how women think because
it was their random selection
not everyone no I mean I don't think
everyone there's some women that would
be like no like take me not not you my
mom would say that my mom would say
rather her than me yeah but you're her
child of course any mother most women
are saying take the guy I mean it's the
same thing in the Titanic it was women
and children but I think that's like a
premise that they used to have in the
past that they wanted isn't that I think
I think that's natural like I think I
think men feel the innate instinct to
protect women the same way women have
the innate instinct to protect children
when when why is that violence towards
women what if they have an innate
Instinct well it's actually
um one-sided domestic abuse is more
common for the woman to be hitting the
man than the man to be hitting the woman
most domestic abuse situations they're
hitting each other so you can't yeah
like because a lot of girls do that
they'll say I was abused I was hit I was
whatever but let me let me finish but
they'll forget about the part where
they're like they're heading back and so
like like there is violence against
women but it's not it's not the norm but
doesn't that go against like the
intrinsic world to protect women yeah
when that I don't know go against the
laws of evolution for them to want to do
that I would say yeah it probably does
yeah but but that's why it's not normal
even when um even when you know uh from
uh holy books they say you know a woman
was made from Adam's Eve was made from
what Adam's Rib that's literally uh it's
not literal it literally means uh a man
needs to keep a woman under his arm for
protection and close to his heart like
it's a matter it's not literal so this
is from way back
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats and then
I'm gonna close out the show so any
final thoughts you guys have you know
think now while I read
um okay guys make sure you like the
video um subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell the like is
the most important metric that YouTube
uses to push out these live streams so
make sure you like also subscribe to the
channel we're almost to 400 000
subscribers like we're literally so
close I think we'll hit it next week
um so yeah make sure you hit that
subscribe button so John um yarbor in
1990 during Desert Storm eighty percent
of women sent for rear support got
pregnant just to leave there were
volunteers scared of Dying mgtow by
Logic Pro wasn't given the show she
earned it mgtow by Logic you're not put
in a leadership position you earn
leadership positions
um American virus is freedom she is
completely wrong about military
leadership people are things and tools
to leaders three-time Afghan vet in
Special Ops Mike 910b from a 20 year old
retire vet the chick in the middle is
mental she stopped speaking on something
you read from a book Christopher surdak
leaders don't say I feel every 35
seconds leaders act on facts and
objective realities not fantasies in
their head
Clifford range officers were soldiers
when they started barely hear men's
issues do not diminish women's issues
why is it that every time we address
something for men women have to make it
about them John yarber his hypocrisy is
the problem women love it mgtem by Logic
it took three minutes after showing the
video before a woman said but at some
but some men allow this stuff so it's
men's fault men are always the victim
even when men women are always the
victim even when women murdered him in
Cold Blood wow typical Brit Cormier a
lot of women say sa should be the same
a lot of women say essay should be the
same penalty no matter who did it
however remember when the hashtag
believe all women or believe women was
all over the place why not believe all
victims Christopher cerdach I feel like
but I told you she couldn't do it
another feminist men cheer and candidate
modern diagnosis
modern diet diogenes love from Alaska
question do you think men are
demotivated to become successful because
women value indicators of success more
than traits men
because women value the indicators of
success more than the traits men need in
order to become successful also is
credit makeup for men
um nelium that man with the cane was in
the man with the cane was in a
motorcycle accident was completely
paralyzed work to be able to walk just
to have that happen wow Clifford range
Pearl I get that I feel jar ASAP the
sense of entitlement is scary they cut
they can murder but it's the man's fault
um and then that was yeah I read that
one already I'm gonna refresh it real
quick just to make sure all super chats
guys are going towards getting blessing
and 8K camera
um that's going to be a big thing for
reaction videos
um Jason from Minnesota hyena females
are much larger hyena females are much
larger larger than males because they
would not eat if they were dwarfed like
other species sentience and men's
interest intrinsic intrinsic instinct to
protect and provide is innate intact but
if the woman disrespects her man he
shuts off that instinct and the survival
Instinct kicks in equal rights equals
equal equal rights equals equal lefts
you earn my protection not demand it
Chris Henson loved the show glad to hear
all the perspectives John yarber what
are they teaching this these days
Christopher Pearl and over 85 percent of
confirmed cases of child abuse the
abuser is a woman usually the mother you
can't find the studies anymore Google
suppresses them I'm John yarbor in 1990
Desert Storm 80 oh I read that one okay
um final thoughts and then go around
uh and where people can find you
she has funny stories they're funny on
Instagram I'm I'm kind of new to social
media I'm trying my best I'm trying my
best um going back to the the topic of
our modern women I think they're tens or
something right yeah
um look we we know the reality is that
they're probably not a 10 and the thing
is I say this from the heart uh it will
save you a lot of time and it will come
back to regret you know you'll have a
lot of regret and everything down the
line if you just accept and practice
radical acceptance
and this is what they teach in therapy
as well a lot of therapy you can
actually do it yourself in terms of just
talking and being realistic uh perhaps
if you do practice radical acceptance
you actually your life will get a lot
healthier and the irony is is that if
you are realistic and looked at you
looked at yourself objectively you would
actually genuinely start feeling good
about yourself and start improving
yourself and becoming a healthy so
that's what I advocate and also um if
you have a friend if you're going
through difficulty let's just say
medically or whatever and you have a
friend and all your friends are
encouraging you yeah you're fine you're
fine
be a bit more skeptical about their
motives and their agenda and um
yeah I mean look I genuinely care about
people so I will say the truth no one's
got time to to wait around we only have
one life and uh yeah I I really really
do Advocate to get healthy your diet
what you're reading what you're
listening to everything has an impact on
you so uh yeah and that's it oh my
Instagram is Shahara uh underscore Isla
Isla and yeah I look forward to loads of
more conversations
thank you
I just want to thank everybody for
watching the show I think it's so
important to like I love coming on the
show because I love hearing everyone's
opinions I think it's really important
to have your ideas confronted and
challenged
um I like hearing people's honest
opinions and people's ideas I think
that's what you guys are here for as
well like you want to listen to other
people's perspectives as well and I
really appreciate that and it's really
important to do so I just want to say
like thanks for watching the show and
keep supporting Paul
um all the most of the problems we've
listed the way certain people like in
our comments for example you know men
are like when men problems are brought
up women problems are brought up I think
it's very easy to end up in like a echo
chamber where what you what you think is
kind of like ends up becoming what you
just perceive sometimes it's good you
need to keep an open mind all the time
like men have issues women have issues I
think in a sense that um in that sense
yeah we are equal different roles but we
are equal because I can't I can't tell
my my god oh I'm more important than him
he's more this that the other
um and yeah I just think you just need
to you need to keep an open mind all the
time I don't think it's good to
sometimes it's good being black and
white but most of the time we're too
complex humans are too complex we're not
just we're not bound to just one thing
you need to uh understand a lot of
people's behavior and perceptions
Outlook is just like projection of
themselves so yeah that's all I have to
say thank you
you're gonna say where they can find you
well oh um Instagram is yy50 underscore
underscore
um as long as I think the girls hit the
nail on the head so obviously he's not
seen me here before
hit me up on Insta who's underscore
Eddie underscore
policy making in the future
okay guys um thank you for coming on a
round of applause for the panel
um guys don't forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell
let's get to 400k we are so close
um while you're at it don't forget to
subscribe to our two clips channels just
pearly clips and pearl daily um sign up
for our memberships we have the five
dollar tier that lets you be a part of
the chat the 10 tier you get the Discord
and the behind the scenes Vlogs
um we also have you get to connect with
me on social media for the third tier
and for the fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month
honestly guys I am so good at YouTube
help I kill YouTube help I've gotten so
many people to 10 20 30k um I help them
on Tick Tock too so honestly I think
that is like literally where you'll get
the most value is um the one-on-one call
once a month on top of that go follow my
Instagram
just.pearlythings you have to put in the
whole thing
um because I'm Shadow band but I'm
really close to 50K so go follow that go
follow my Tick Tock just pearlythings.4
and dot five um those are my backup
accounts in case you know they take away
that one
um we have a Members Only Live coming up
next week of DM Eddie if you want to get
on the show don't forget to subscribe to
the channel like the video on your way
out and I will talk to you next time